hey you guys flickers of fear again and
we're still doing folk horror february
this is actually a movie that i had been
wanting to see for a while i remember
seeing the trailer for this
gosh it was like a really long time ago
i think i saw the trailer in the theater
so it must have been for another a24
movie because this is an a24 movie so
i'm trying to think of like the last a24
movie that i might have seen in the
theater which might have been the lodge
i kind of want to say but uh i remember
seeing the trailer for this which is
called lamb
and seeing the trailer i was just like
oh my god that looks weird as [ __ ] and
i'm here for it so
and then i but then like i kind of
forgot about it
and then when i was thinking about uh
some folk horror stuff and i was like
what should i do for the last two and i
was kind of i saw a couple that i was
gonna do and i didn't really like them
all that much i said man i kind of
wanted to do something
you know maybe a little bit different so
i was trying to watch some different
ones and then i remembered this one so i
went and rented it so this movie came
out in 2021 i guess it got a wide
release maybe in october because i kind
of feel like that's when a lot of the
other reviews of this came out but uh so
yeah it's taken me a while to get around
to it and as i said the trailer really
really looked intriguing now again this
is an a24 movie um it's pretty weird
uh as a lot of their movies tend to be
and it's not gonna be for everybody uh i
kind of feel like they were marketing it
a little bit as a horror movie
which
it sort of is but it's actually kind of
more like a dark fairy tale it's you
know what i mean it's more like a
folklore type of story so it doesn't
really have a lot of horrific elements
to it but
i don't know there was just something
about this one
that really struck me i really really
liked this a lot uh but as with most a24
movies this one's uh seems very divisive
people were either really really into it
or they really really hated it and
didn't really i don't want to say they
didn't necessarily get it because it is
um
very much uh a slow burn type of thing
uh a lot of it is not spelled out um you
know it's kind of the the kind of movie
where you just have to pick up on a lot
of context clues interestingly when i
watched like uh
some other reviews of this movie one
thing that a lot of people said was that
when they were first watching it
um you know they liked it okay and stuff
but they found themselves liking it much
more like the more they thought about it
like you know maybe a day or two later
and i don't know i guess because i
watched it
i don't know probably like uh three or
four days ago now
and
that's true now i did love it the first
time i watched it which i was just
enthralled like the whole entire time
yes it's very slow there's not a lot of
dialogue particularly in the first third
but
it didn't really bother me there was
just something about the whole like tone
of it the whole vibe of it that really
just kind of like sucked me in
and so i was just like hypnotized and
enthralled the whole time
but um you know so
it just it depends though but then the
more the more i think about it i think i
have the same thing too like i i'm just
liking it a lot more
now one thing that i did notice was that
some people uh are kind of categorizing
it's like oh well it has like dark
comedic elements which i suppose it does
um
depending on how you look at it though
because honestly there were a couple
things in here that were kind of like
funny like in a very very subdued
dark humor kind of way
you know not outright zany or anything
and maybe depending on how you look at
it some of the imagery could be funny
just because it's so
strange uh and so uncomfortable and now
i'm not going to try to like i'm not i
don't want to spoil the ending of this
or anything but there is one reveal that
happens about 30 40 minutes into the
movie which i probably will spoil but
only because
the trailer and the stills from the
movie kind of spoiled it so it's not
really that big of a surprise if you've
seen the trailer and the stills but if
you don't want to know what that reveal
is then
maybe you want to watch the movie first
before you get into this i'm not going
to spoil the ending like i said but i
will kind of spoil what that reveal is
so this is a an icelandic film
uh nimiro pass is in it
now uh the director
was is named uh
valdemar johansen and they're all like
icelandic names so
please forgive me if i mess any of them
up
uh the screenplay was actually uh the
director co-wrote the screenplay and the
other uh writer on it was uh a guy named
seon who works with bjork a lot uh a
lyricist a writer
things of that nature so uh you kind of
see where this is going and like i said
this is a very
folkloric type of story so
approach it like that it's almost kind
of like magical realism i want to say i
was watching um mark kermode and like
the the guy that he was that was he was
talking to about this movie and that
other guy asked is it like pan's
labyrinth and i was like
it's i guess in some ways it's not it's
a similar kind of tone maybe to like a
guillermo del toro but not as
fantastical
this one is pretty much very very
grounded in reality with just one little
touch of
the supernatural or
not necessarily supernatural but you
know not
exactly natural you know i'll get into
that in a minute
so what we have
is uh numerous and uh plays a woman
named maria and her and her partner
husband uh whoever her husband's name is
uh ingvar
and they are farmers so they have this
remote farm out in iceland
and so the first third of the film
is kind of like just showing them like i
said there's not a hell of a lot of
dialogue it's just kind of showing them
sort of going about their
day-to-day life it's a very isolated
farm they live out in the you know in
the middle of nowhere these big
mountains uh there's a lot of fog it's
set around christmas time
which is significant to some of the
symbolism of the story and uh there's
also kind of like uh it's set at the
time of year when the sun doesn't set
all the way so which actually took me a
couple minutes to like realize i'm like
why are they going to bed it's still
light out and then i was like oh duh
yeah it's isolated but yeah so sometimes
the sun doesn't go down so it's just so
it's light like the whole time there's
no nighttime or anything
now there's a hint that something kind
of weird is going on at the beginning
um you don't really have any context for
it until later on but at the very
beginning of the
movie there's kind of like
you're almost kind of like seeing things
from the perspective of something and it
you can hear like this weird breathing
and like there's all these little ponies
and stuff and they run away like they're
spooked or whatever
so then you're going into the first
third of the movie with this couple just
kind of showing them going about their
life on the farm
doing all the work
and
it's unspoken but there's some kind of
there's a melancholy you know that's
kind of hanging around you don't really
know what it is you don't figure it out
until later on
but
you know that's no one's
outright sad or anything like that but
you can tell that they're just kind of
like you know going through the motions
and this is what they're doing they have
a couple like conversations that maybe
could hint about something like they're
eating breakfast or something and he
says he's reading this article about oh
they think that
time travel into the future is
theoretically possible and maria says
well i think i'd rather you know go back
to the past or something like that so
you know that there's something going on
that's that they're not really like
talking about
now so they're doing the work on the
farm now it turns out that it is uh
lambing season so all of their sheep are
you know giving birth to their lambs as
happens at this time of year
and uh they they point out they're like
you know the apparently the farm is
doing quite well um they're having you
know there are more lambs born this year
than last year and the year before that
was better than last year so there's all
this other stuff
at one point though there's just one
lamb
or this one uh you actually and she kind
of uh doesn't give birth at first i
don't think they're entirely sure that
she's pregnant at first even though
she's acting like she is
um but then like after most of the other
lambs have been birthed this one gives
birth
now they don't show the baby at first um
you know that there's something
different about it just
because they don't show it and because
it seems like it's a much more difficult
birth than they were having with the
other ones i don't know
when i was watching this i'm sitting
there going did they legit get real
pregnant sheep
and then like numero power said like the
actor that plays ingar um are they
actually like helping these sheep
giveaways just like really really good
special effects because that really
looks like real sheep giving birth so
you know if if you're grossed out by
that then
maybe you might want to skip skip over
those parts because it is if it's fake
it's the most realistic [ __ ] i've ever
seen but uh but yeah so so they don't
show that you know they should kind of
show uh invar trying to get in there and
get the baby out and everything and then
you hear the baby kind of like flop on
the floor of the barn
and then the two of them kind of like
exchange this look with one another and
it's just this very enigmatic look
almost kind of like
at first it's a little bit like surprise
but then it's just kind of like uh okay
you know what i mean so it's that kind
of thing
and you're just kind of like okay i
wonder what the hell is going on there
so what they do is they take this lamb
this baby lamb and they take it into
their house and start treating it like
it's their actual baby
now as i said at first they don't show
this lamb that you you can see the head
and like sometimes like it has a little
blanket on
and it's really interesting because as i
said a lot of this is conveyed not
through dialogue a lot of it is conveyed
through facial expressions or other kind
of like context clues or if it is
dialogue it's usually like um
like indirect they're saying something
that maybe kind of means something else
so at first you're kind of thinking that
ingvar
i mean maria is all in with this she's
got the baby and the swaddled in the uh
blanket and she's you know rocking it
and treating it just like a human child
and at first inggvar is just kind of
like i i don't know how i feel about
this like you can tell from his facial
expression that he's thinking that but
he seems to kind of warm to it later on
and honestly as the movie goes on they
both start treating this uh this lamb
just like their real baby now as i said
um
the reveal
that they that comes about 30 40 minutes
into the film uh i will spoil that
because as i said i'm pretty sure they
showed it in the trailers and the still
so what this lamb this
this creature has a lamb's head and one
lamb arm
and then the rest of it is human so it's
a hybrid creature uh props to the
special effects department on this i
think it was partly puppetry and partly
cgi it looks
amazing
and this little creature is so
[ __ ] cute that you just can't even
i just couldn't even it was just like so
cute and then when they put when she
gets a little bit older because
obviously lambs grow faster than human
babies do so when she gets a little bit
older and they start putting a little
clothes on her and stuff like that i was
just kind of like oh my gosh i just
kidding it was just like the cutest [ __ ]
ever she doesn't talk uh they call her
ada
and again start raising her like a human
child and you can tell like
the whole entire mood changes at this
point because they're just kind of like
uh before like i said they seemed kind
of like melancholy and now everything is
just like happiness they're just like
you know so ecstatic now one kind of
thing that's a problem though is that
this lamb's mother
the sheep uh keeps coming back to the
house and like you know bleeding at the
window like to pay give me my baby back
you [ __ ] you know understandably
and uh you know maria's like kind of not
having it uh so that kind of goes a
certain kind of way
and so just when they have this whole
little family unit established
uh then then some chaos comes into the
mix in the form of this dude named peter
who is actually ingvar's brother
now uh peter is kind of like a little
bit of a deadbeat a little bit of
obviously
he seems like not a terrible person but
he doesn't really seem like all that
great a person either and it's really
interesting how they introduce him he's
actually introduced like i guess like a
group of his friends like drive him out
to the farm
where ingvar and maria live and
they drive this car out there and then
they pull him out the trunk
and like leave him on the road like
throw his cell phone like [ __ ] off man
so they never tell you like what he did
to like piss his friends off and [ __ ]
like that but it's just that says so
much like that introduction
so he comes to the farm
and
at this point ada the little their
little lamb child
is kind of like i guess maybe about the
size of like a five-year-old or
something five or six years old and like
i said they have little clothes for her
and everything like that
and
understandably uh the brother peter he
sees this and he's just kind of like and
the one thing that made me laugh more
than anything was peter's facial
expression the first time that he sees
ada just like his face just
conveyed just like a whole cosmos of
emotions just in one it was just like
this the one of the best like what the
[ __ ] faces i've ever seen
but yeah so that that kind of thing was
like funny to me it's weird because i
kind of feel like some people and i saw
uh somebody commented on a video like a
review about this where they said when
they saw this in the theater
like when the reveal was made that otto
was you know half lamb half human um
everyone kind of laughed and i was kind
of like i don't know it didn't seem
funny to me um
i don't and i'm not really sure why that
is like i didn't
it didn't really make me it's like i
said the whole thing has a very
folkloric
uh you know fairy tale type of feel to
it not as i said not fantastical
but it has this kind of magical realism
vibe to it so and you know there's a lot
of folklore about kind of half human
half
animal like hybrids and things so it's
like to me it didn't seem altogether it
didn't seem funny or anything
um i just thought otto was cute as a
button
and
i just thought it was cute you know what
i mean so i don't know so it wasn't like
funny to me but it you know when they
started putting clothes on and stuff
like i said it wasn't funny but um it
was i just thought it was kind of like
adorable
so uh so yeah so peter
is like not having it and he's just like
what the [ __ ] he's like
why like why are you playing house with
this animal
and it's like what the hell is even the
matter with you at which point you kind
of find out that
the reason why this happened and why
they named her ada was because you were
led to believe again they don't really
state this outright
but you were led to believe that maria
and ingvar had had a daughter
whose name was ada who died somehow
presumably i don't know if it was an
accident or if it was they never really
tell you um i kind of have some ideas
about it just from some various context
clues and stuff but like i said it's
very subdued um and it could it's kind
of like left to interpretation and the
thing about it is that that's why they
had you know kids clothes that's why
they had a crib already that's why they
had all this stuff because they had had
a kid at some point that died and so to
them
uh ada being born from this
from a you
you know and she's like a half human
half uh animal hybrid
it was like um almost like a miracle you
know what i mean and also like i said
because this takes place on christmas
you have the whole like lamb innocent
like christianity type of thing it's not
overblown but there is like a lot of
symbolism in it and i will note too that
the poster um i think this has a couple
different posters but the one like kind
of iconic poster which i actually really
like uh is sort of like a painting of
numero pass and she's like holding the
lamb and it looks kind of like an old
school like madonna and child sort of
painting a little bit even though she's
wearing like modern clothes and stuff
but i really did like that kind of like
symbolism in there
so uh as i said i don't really want to
spoil too much of it but
you know once the brother shows up uh
and is kind of like what the [ __ ] is
happening
then it kind of goes in one particular
direction and i will say that the ending
of this
uh
i guess i shouldn't have been surprised
as i was maybe i wasn't paying as much
attention like to some of the context
clues at the beginning or i had
forgotten them by the time we got to the
end
but
i mean when i was watching it and then
the end happened and i said out loud to
myself well i wasn't expecting that
i don't know why i wasn't uh in
hindsight i should have been but uh but
i wasn't so uh again this is going to be
i actually loved this movie i thought
the cinematography was gorgeous
um as most a24 movies are
there was something about it and like i
said i don't know if i'd necessarily
call it a horror movie but it did have
this real like ominous
even from the very beginning like when
you were watching them just like go
about their work on the farm like even
before otto was born
there was just something very like
ominous or like you know i don't know
it's just i had this weird like dread
feeling in the pit of my stomach maybe
it was because
movies about
animals like this
um and particularly one like this
um i'm always like afraid that something
bad is gonna happen to the animals
and
you know and especially like the scenes
where like the mother
sheep like comes back as trying to get
the baby back from them like because
they've taken the baby in the house and
that part was like really upsetting to
me so
i don't know why and i think i've said
that before it's like i'm in in movies
i'm like usually more bothered by stuff
happening to animals than i am to people
depending on what it is so maybe that's
why i just felt like this really kind of
was like oh my god please and there's
also like a dog and a cat in this and i
was just kind of like oh man please
don't let now i will say again spoiler
alert uh something bad does happen to
the dog but the cat's okay so
because i because after the bad thing
happened to the dog i was just kind of
like [ __ ] no and then like everything i
saw the kitty a couple times i'm like
kitty no it's like please hurt the kitty
it's like every time i see that movie
but yeah um but yeah so
how you
i don't know how you feel about this
movie
this one's kind of like a difficult and
i kind of feel like a lot of a24 movies
they're difficult for me to like
recommend to people because i never
really know even people that like this
kind of movie you never know how it's
gonna hit you you know what i mean um
but this movie i think this just it hit
me just like right in the right way i
think i immediately like got right into
the vibe of it that it was this kind of
like folkloric um you know like a like a
old-fashioned like folklore type of
story about and it's almost like a
morality tale too
um the fact that these humans you know
that they're sympathetic because they're
going through the grief of like losing
their kid but was it right for them to
take
you know this hybrid creature which
wasn't really theirs uh and raise it as
their own um i even saw some people say
this was almost kind of like um
like a strange
metaphor for like some like adoption or
some other things like that because you
know these are the parents and they're
taking this uh this kid away from the
from the parents like in you know the
mother sheep didn't really have a say in
it
and uh and so there was that kind of
thing but i i don't know there was just
something like i said not exactly a
horror movie but it does have something
like really like kind of unsettling
about it did have some kind of like
darkly comedic elements a little bit
although i did not find the reveal
of uh otta of the sheep creature child
um i didn't find that particularly funny
i just i was just rolling with it and i
was just kind of like okay well i mean
and i kind of suspected
uh because i'd seen the trailer and i
kind of suspected because they weren't
showing the body they were just showing
the head like for a long time of the of
the lamb which just looked like a lamb's
head um so i was like oh that i bet that
has a human body you know what i mean so
i guess it was like it was that kind of
thing so it didn't really like strike me
as particularly funny like when i saw it
i just thought it was kind of cute and i
just rolled with it as a folklore
element so it's like a magical realism
thing uh but this is definitely a movie
that
it is bizarre uh
you know what like i said when i saw the
trailer at first i was like wow that
looks weird as [ __ ] it is weird as [ __ ]
but
i don't know it's the more i think about
it like the less weird it seems to me if
that makes any sense but as again i
don't know if i'd i mean i loved it
but i can see how some people would just
be like oh my god what the [ __ ] like
nothing happens or
they can't get into it and stuff does
happen in it but i will say the first
third it didn't bother me but the first
third is very very slow and there's very
very little dialogue um you know before
the lamb creature is born you're just
kind of watching them go about their
lives and then
you know for a long time you don't see
that otta is a hybrid and so you're just
wondering why these crazy people are
raising this lamb like why they took
this particular lamb into their house
and are raising it like a human baby
and until you figure out that it's a
thing until all these context clues come
to
fruition and you figure out what's
really going on like behind all of this
um then it starts to make a lot more
sense and you get a lot more
emotionally invested or at least i did i
was actually very emotionally invested
in this um and so
so it was like a really really tragic uh
sort of story as well i found it very
sad
um but you know
if you've seen it let me know what you
thought about it did you think it was
funny did you think it was boring you
know i'm really curious to see what
everybody thought about this one because
i really really liked it but i can see
how
different people might have differing
opinions on it and like i said i did see
some reviewers that actually really
really hated it a lot um so we'll see
but yeah have let's have a discussion
about it in the comments so that will do
it for this flickers of fear continuing
on with folk or february and i will see
you guys on the next one
bye